let's get into the first big story
breaking news
breaking news from earlier today
armed man who wanted to kill brett
kavanaugh arrested near justice's home
california man was in possession of a
gun and burglary tools
the man 26 year old nicholas john rosk
of simi simi valley california was
carrying a firearm according to fox news
he also had burglary tools the federal
affidavit filed against the would-be
assailant states rosk was in possession
of pepper spray zip ties a hammer a
crowbar duct tape and a tactical knife
in addition to a glock 17 pistol with
two magazines and ammunition
sources for the post claimed the man was
angered over a leaked draft of a
february supreme court opinion that
could possibly signal the overturning of
roe v wade they indicated he was also
upset about the recent spate of mass
shootings this is clearly
modern democrat liberal politics
motivating this guy to try and kill a
supreme court justice i want to show you
this
this is the southern poverty law
center's uh poll that came out one week
ago
section four partisanship and violence
total approval for quote assassinating a
politician who is harming the country or
our democracy
shockingly younger republican men one
third of them agree with that
younger democratic men 44 the largest
group support political assassinations
now i know it's bad because we have this
young democrat-minded individual who was
apparently attempt he's charged with
attempted murder that's it charged with
attempted murder
young republican women were at 40
percent right supportive assassinations
and young republican men at 34
young democrats talking about earlier
yeah that's the other side of the aisle
that's what i'm that's the concern
honestly you know i mean you talk about
violence in the streets it's probably
it's probably why young the reason i
would say young republican men are
probably
of young the younger demographic the
least likely to support that well
they're not young democrat women were
the least likely but i would say one of
the reasons younger republican men are
lower in support of this is because many
of them may have actually seen violence
many of them oh yeah veterans absolutely
but that's the thing
it's the younger group
of people you know it's not the older
group so it's the next generation coming
up that they're so frustrated with our
political system right now that this is
what they believe the alternative is and
it is
if people aren't being heard that is the
alternative for sure it doesn't matter
what side the hell you're born that's
what you see it all the time those are
revolutions come from another aspect to
understand here is that the younger
generation is more emotionally unstable
is more likely to be in poverty has less
ability for upward uh economic mobility
a
dumped with big pharma medicines on top
of having
not harmonious relationships with
partners so when you add all of that up
you have the perfect recipe for
radicalization because if you look at
what's been happening in the middle east
you see a lot of guys who are not
intelligent iq is also going down here
in the united states that's also a
correlation with violence so it's
poverty so it's relationship status you
see all of those factors going down so
politically we are prepping the next
generation of the youth to be violent
people especially what you look at the
mind control that's happening on big
tech social media that is pushing them
to these radical ideas by censoring free
speech by censoring debate and only
allowing echo chambers to be heard
radicalizing individuals towards their
political opinions even further which is
extremely dangerous and to me this is
all being done deliberately a part of a
divide and conquer agenda so people
fight each other rather than look at the
true culprits of the problems that are
being created for them yep i would agree
with that i talk about a lot actually
one of my favorite days um in my
lifetime is actually september 12th
2001.
the day after 9 11 when you know we're
still reeling in pain everybody's in
shock uh compare you know because of
what happened
but in that time the images that were
coming out people were covered in ashes
from the towers and everything doesn't
matter what color you were it didn't
matter who you voted for in the last
election cycle didn't matter what your
your gender was or what religion you
were an american and we had your back
and that's what we have to get back to
if we don't get back to that
then what are we going to do with the
nation i was there in new york city the
dust went into my neighborhood and i
also you know i think we should be
careful after that we also went into you
know iraq we went to afghanistan we got
ourselves into a mess there was a lot of
cohesion there was a lot of patriot
patriotism but
the political parties inside of the
united states used it for their own
personal advantage helping the
military-industrial complex leading us
astray with our foreign policy creating
a lot of devastating situations that i
think you know we should we're looking
back on were absolute mistakes that we
relied into so if we could i was there
too actually i lived there and i
remember hanging out with everybody on
the 12th and sitting out at lunch just
talking and feeling it like making eye
contact with people walking down the
street
i want that without the tragedy sure
without the deficit we don't need to
scare people into that but there was a
cohesion there was an energy we're in
this together you know you know my
friends my family were a part of this
and and you looked at your neighbor you
saw someone that was you know a part of
your country because you know the the
whole idea was we were attacked we need
to come together so there was a lot of
strength in that moment and there was a
lot of you know amazing things that
could have happened but i just i just
think you know we always got to be all
so careful in those moments as well the
federal reserve system it it's a form of
attack inflation is a kind of theft like
you said earlier luke and it's not a
joke no it's the largest tax if people
felt that attack like like september
11th i think there would be a lot more
of unity uh around it as a form of
national but they're gonna start feeling
it people can only but people can only
understand for the most the average
person only understands single-layer
issues
so they say
why don't i make enough money at my job
or or they say more importantly why
can't i afford to buy gas and what do
you get from the average you know
millennial or particularly millennial
females who vote democrat it's because
i'm not being paid enough by my boss
right
that's not the case that's not the case
and so they say we need to raise the
minimum wage and you say okay that's
layer one
what's layer two to that proposal
increasing the minimum wage results in
just generic inflation across the board
and it and it creates only a temporary
relief that doesn't actually solve the
problem yeah but six months
if that's
if that
yeah and so you know you try to explain
basic economics to people the the
minimum wage is completely meaningless
completely what matters is how much can
you buy for the equivalent of one hour
of labor
so they say well then we should pay more
but that number doesn't mean anything
because when you just make everybody
have to be paid a base rate then the
base co base cost of good has to go up
they like to point out like denmark and
they're like well in denmark they pay 20
bucks an hour and a burger is only two
bucks totally different economy value
systems and a different value of labor
per hour than we have you can't solve
cultural problems with policy yeah no i
absolutely agree with you and that's one
of the things that you know being a
small business owner one of the things i
talked to with all my you know staff
about i was talking one of my buddies
and uh when when the minimum wage went
up that was a great idea like well sure
it's a great idea except for now you're
just simply reducing your purchasing
power it's going to happen in time
you're going to have a cycle it's going
to come back around and then very very
soon he was like wait a minute all of
our supplies are way more expensive now
and it took about six months
i said yep and it's going to take you
about three or four years for us to
catch up to be charging again what we
had again two years ago it's also just
one thing really quickly the financial
components are important here but just
back to this kavanaugh story because
this is this is a big story this is
something major that has been building
up incrementally uh to the point where
even the department of homeland security
just issued a new memo saying that
there's most likely a very big chance
for more violence this summer
politically because of the midterms
because of the border crisis because of
the supreme court decisions so even
homeland security is warning saying
there's going to be some internal
violence and turmoil happening here in
the united states how do we de-escalate
it when almost every single factor big
tech social media the corporate
mainstream media every politician is
adding fuel to the fire how do we stop
you can't
yep i i don't think it's possible maybe
it was possible
six years ago
maybe it wasn't maybe with donald trump
he you know he really broke these people
but that i i believe that you know i've
been i've been covering
i was covering conflict and crisis
at occupy wall street yeah i started
covering it for vice i covered a little
bit when i was working for fusion the
abc news company
and i don't see a path towards bringing
this country together
what i see is
you have uh what i i like to reference
stephen marsh he wrote the book the next
civil war when he said to us that you
have a multicultural democracy and a
constitutional republic in the same in
the same country trying to fight for
control and you can't have both and he's
completely right
i believe in a constitutional republic
you know uh i've tr i i grew up
traditionally democrat but the reason
why today
people who used to be on the left like
elon musk or joe rogan are called
right-wing is because they still believe
in those values of a constitutional
republic
the left
absolute chaos
you right now
you have occupy wall street activists
that i know tweeting in defense
of telling children it's not going to
lick itself well they have no principles
they have no moral standard other than i
want power fu
one side has no principles one side has
standardized principles and various
disagreements you've got post liberals
libertarians moderates centrists and
conservatives in one side and then you
have the psychotic death cult on the
other side right there was
confrontations there was fighting
outside of that dallas uh venue where
they were doing those sick things with
children there was activists coming
there saying no we're going to fight
anyone who's protesting this this is the
insane level that we reach that's what
we need to understand i want to explain
what i just said psychotic death cult
because i hear it all the time from the
left and msnbc they're like the trump
supporters and occult let me explain the
q anon people i think they're nuts i
completely disagree with conservative
christians on a lot of moral issues but
we can sit down and talk about the
constitution the founding documents the
rules by which we seek to compromise and
self-govern i can sit here and say i
disagree with you conservative on tax
policy and then we all laugh get along
and tell each other jokes the other side
puts a big neon sign up saying it's not
going to lick itself they fire bomb
buildings they had we had the worst
riots we've ever seen and it's all lies
and i'm not just talking about leftists
i'm talking about the mainstream press
the corporate press msnbc had the nerve
to come out and be like what a shocking
story this man had weapons and he was at
kavanaugh's home msnbc
they advocated msnbc ran a story saying
it was good that they were going to his
house
these people are absolutely deranged
look when trump comes out and says
something i outright say i think i think
he's wrong he talks about fraud all the
time i'm like nah that guy's wrong and
they call us a cult no i'm telling you
that guy's wrong but they come out on
their own platform and say it's good
we're going to his house then it happens
to go oh heaven's me
they're in a cult they just they prop up
whatever is not
the right or whatever is not america and
that extends to the point where they've
lost their minds and you have adult men
taking dollar bills from children into
bikinis and thongs you have this thing
in dallas where it says it's not gonna
lick itself and they're like this is a
good a normal thing and it's
family-friendly and i'm like no you just
have no principles no standards no
morals and all you do is fight for power
for whatever your side is and your side
is basically whatever the other is not
no you're absolutely right they actually
treat it like a faith system
that's what's interesting to me i mean
so
amidst everything else i'm also an
ordinary minister so they treat it very
much like a base system they promote it
like one to f defend it like one and and
the interesting thing is i mean even
saying liberals anymore i don't think
it's accurate right i really don't i
mean i have friends that that were
liberals five years ago
but they i wouldn't call them a liberal
now they the liberal is gone these
they've really been taken over by
radicals this is radical liberalism well
the interesting thing that happened is
that you had the the principled liberals
have become what's called disaffected or
post liberal yep and the people who are
just tribalists have become
establishment or leftist right but it's
it's funny because you look at a lot of
these younger leftists they're pro guns
but they keep defending the
establishment and the the psychopathy of
this cult
yeah it's crazy that's why i'm sorry
look
when
i just got to put it this way
when they come out
and they have children on stage at 21
and up gay bars desmond is amazing
ripping off his clothing and being
handed money to do so that's called
stripping yeah and i'm not exaggerating
anybody who knows anything about what
stripping is knows that bikini bars are
fully clothed women dancing on poles and
shaking it for men for cash but they're
wearing clothes when you have a little
boy on stage and he rips his clothes off
for adult gay men who give him money
pedophilia these are pedophiles and the
left overtly defends it and what do you
get in florida when a reasonable
proposal is made maybe parents should
know about this they say you're trying
to ban gay people it's like dude if you
want to defend pedophiles that's on you
but this is why i don't think there's
reconciliation
yeah and maybe not especially for some
of these issues
and i talk a lot about especially with
the campaign how you think about things
on a different level honestly quite
honestly i think everybody should run
for office because it makes you think
about things in a different level than
you ever would have before um it's
really interesting but i talk a lot
about just getting back to our founding
principles of faith family and freedom
like these very basic things that you
know some people call them trite i think
if we don't get back to the things that
made us great to start with i think
we're doomed as a nation and so some of
that i think is absolutely right i think
it ties into what you're talking about
right now well the crazy thing to me is
like you know policy wise i've always
been rather liberal sure but this day
and age not anymore well it's i'm sorry
like we had a guy on the show as
progressive who said i asked him do you
think women should be able to get an
abortion at nine months and he said it's
the woman's choice and i'm like why kill
the baby you can end the pregnancy by
delivering the baby and let the baby
live and just drop it at a fire
department it's like a woman's choice
i'm like
okay there's nothing there but then you
have california that now trying to
advocate post post-term abortion and
you've heard it they've owned the street
i've heard people say in interviews they
said well seven days after birth you
know if
a woman decides to give up on the life
of her child should she be charged like
you mean murder a child
in in virginia so so do you remember
this in virginia i think it was kathy
tran was her name she she proposed a
bill no restriction abortion and she was
asked i think was by a judge he said if
if a woman is dilating at the point of
birth could you abort the baby and she
said there would be no restrictions it's
disgusting that's in virginia it's evil
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you